hey guys it's max we just got in the
brand new eighth generation
ipad and even though there hasn't been
that many changes
i am super excited for a couple of
reasons that are gonna make it a great
update
if i can actually open up this box and
today we're going to be comparing it
against the ipad mini and now with this
thing
being on sale right now on amazon it's
listed for 349 or even less refurbished
while links in the description this is
going to make it a very tough choice
hey guys future max here i kept calling
the ipad mini 5
the fourth one i just realized that so
please forgive us and let's get back to
the video
don't worry we're going to let you guys
know all of the differences such as the
design differences
the displays performance gaming and some
things that you probably don't expect
and at the end
we will give you guys our opinion now
let's go ahead and open this thing up
here
and it looks identical to the previous
10.2 inch which which
has that larger display compared to
before this is a huge surprise
this is shocking that with a budget ipad
they are including the 20 watt
usb type-c charger with that cable
as well this is typically about 50 bucks
to buy
separately and with the ipad mini just
like the previous budget ipads it comes
with this 12 watt
usb type a charger i was not expecting
that to come with apple's budget tablet
it's gonna make it charge much faster
and you can use it for your iphone as
well
now let's talk about the exterior
differences as you guys could see
the ipad air 10.2 inch the budget one
is much larger in fact if i flip it over
here
and i flip over my ipad mini it will
actually fit
inside of the screen and it's actually
smaller all around so even though
7.9 to 10.2 doesn't sound like a big
difference it definitely is
now the mini also has thinner bezels on
the side over here
and it's also a little thinner as well
as far as comfort in the hand the ipad
mini is definitely more comfortable
because it's a lot smaller
but with that said i feel like i would
expect a bigger weight difference
between the two
the larger one doesn't feel that much
heavier we'll put both weights
right over there for you guys to see the
design is basically the same with the
same touch id
buttons the same speaker placements
which we'll do a speaker test
here in just a bit the only other
exterior
difference is that the ipad 10.2 inch
has
this smart connector and that means that
you can pair it with
a keyboard that even has a trackpad this
is our logitech
combo touch and it basically becomes
a laptop replacement we reviewed this
keyboard it works fantastic the trackpad
works really well because it's using
that smart connector
it is something that works well and it's
something that you can't get with the
ipad mini 4.
and just like last year you still get
the same apple pencil support
for both now let's get into displays and
believe me
apart from the screen size there are a
ton of
differences and we'll show you guys what
that is first let me give a shout out to
our merch you guys can check out the
super comfortable premium
max tech tee in our merch shelf along
with hoodies
masks and a ton of other great stuff
thank you guys for your support
as you guys could see right away from
the above camera
the 10.2 inch ipad looks great there's a
lot less contrast compared to the ipad
mini
and with that there's a massive
difference in reflectivity you can
barely see the camera in the ipad mini
but in the budget ipad you can see the
whole thing
part of the reason is because the ipad
mini 4 has better coatings on the screen
but the other reason probably the bigger
one is that the 10.2 inch budget ipad
has a non-laminated display that means
there's actually an
air gap between the digitizer and the
glass in the actual lcd panel
so if you guys can hear that it sounds
hollow compared to the ipad mini which
sounds a lot more
dense you're basically touching the
screen with that if you're somebody that
plans to draw with the apple pencil
the experience is definitely nicer using
the laminated ipad mini 4
where your drawing is right where the
tip of the pencil is compared to the
budget ipad where you see that gap
and it's a little bit off with that not
only does the ipad mini have better
contrast and less reflectivity
but the colors are better as well
because it supports p3
wide colors as you could tell by this
example you actually see the logo inside
because it could show extra
colors whereas the budget ipad it
doesn't show that at all
along with that the budget ipad also is
missing out on true tone
so the ipad mini will switch the white
balance the color temperature of the
screen depending on your environment
which also is
nice i do have to say though if you're
somebody that's going to be
drawing and you care about that it's
kind of a difficult choice because you
have better colors and contrast
better kind of support and feel versus
larger size and i think i personally
would want the larger size if i was
drawing as far as brightness and
sharpness the ipad mini is very slightly
brighter they're both rated at 500 nits
but i can tell it's a little brighter
and along with that it's also sharper as
well this has 326 ppi compared to 264.
all the text looks perfectly crisp it's
also you know on the smaller screen here
compared to the budget ipad where you
could tell it's not as sharp it's
definitely not bad especially at normal
viewing distances but if you look closer
you can tell the difference and now
let's compare the speakers put on your
best set of headphones
we'll take a listen i'll give you guys
my opinions
[Music]
is
let me know what you guys think down in
the comment section below to me
personally
the ipad mini 4 is a little bit quieter
than the 10.2 inch ipad but the sound
does sound a little bit better it's a
little bit
smoother the highs are a little bit more
balanced and
not as uh maybe crispy sounding
but it is very close and i think it's
close enough not to really matter
with that comes a difference in video
recording both are 1080p
30 frames per second but the 10.2 inch
ipad crops in
a ton as you guys could see the ipad
mini 4 is much wider
and the quality looks quite a bit better
to me as well you guys let me know the
difference in quality
and the difference in microphones down
in the comments section below
as far as battery life the ipad mini 4
has a 19 watt hour battery compared to
32 with a 10.2 inch ipad
but apple rates in both at 10 hours and
in the real world
they are very similar because the mini
has a smaller screen that requires
less power and now let's get into
performance so we're going to start with
geekbench
5 here the cpu test and i'm going to
start
the test here and i can also mention
that both of these have
three gigabytes of ram now when we did
this comparison
last year this is where the ipad really
started falling behind because i had a
really old processor
the a10 this year finally they updated
that to the a12 which is the same exact
one in the ipad mini 4.
the cpu provides a lot better and then
the graphics which we'll test here
is also a lot better and here we have
the scores the single core is actually
identical at 11 14.
the multi-core the ipad mini 4 beats it
out by just a little bit but there are
variances each time
that you run it so they're basically the
same they have the same processor
and this performance is great the
previous 7th generation 10.2
was basically half the performance in
multi-core and that really
limited it now let's go ahead and do our
graphics test
and as far as metal scores we have 5300
on both which is fantastic ipad os 14
also improved the metal performance and
the 10.2
inch ipad is about twice as good as the
previous one last year
and that was a big reason why we told a
lot of people to get the mini instead of
the budget ipad is graphics performance
now as far as gaming you guys can see
some footage here the previous 10.2 inch
ipad really struggled not only did the
graphics look
worse but we had dropped frames we had
stuttering and it wasn't a great
experience
the ipad mini on the other hand it
looked a lot better graphically
it played much smoother and we told
gamers just buy the ipad
mini this time around they have the same
chips that's where it gets a little bit
more difficult the ipad mini is a little
bit more comfortable
in the hand to game but with the larger
one
you have this really nice large display
that's a lot more immersive
if i had to choose one for gaming
personally
i would go for the 10.2 inch ipad as an
adult
i like the larger display now if you're
buying one for
a teenager or especially for a kid
i think the ipad mini might be better
it's a lot more comfortable
and they're gonna have a fine time with
the smaller display
now i'll give you guys my final
conclusion as well but first let's talk
about
the other specs and the prices as far as
pricing the ipad mini comes in at 400
compared to 329 for the 10.2 inch
but that is the msrp prices do go down
and as i mentioned
right now i could buy a brand new ipad
mini 4 for 349
dollars barely any more than the 10.2
inch
with that said the budget ipads always
go
down after a bit um and so you can get a
lower price later as well
not by a whole lot but it does go down
so i'll have the links the latest links
below for you guys to compare
at the time that you're buying and we
also have a difference in
storage the base 10.2 inch comes with 32
gigs
of storage compared to 64 on the ipad
mini
which is nice to have that extra storage
but with all of that considered
if i was choosing one all around it
would have to be the 10.2 inch ipad
yes the screen's not as nice it's more
reflective but
along with that if your screen breaks
it's about half the price to switch it
out yourself which is nice
and you just have a lot more flexibility
with the screen size for drawing
you can get yourself a case with a
keyboard and a trackpad you guys can
check out a review on this as well
it's just a lot more versatile i think
it is the better
buy but let me know your thoughts down
in the comment section
below this has been max with max tech
and we'll see you
in the next video
you